thanks for joining us here at noon i'm
heather mills accused murderer robert
telus in court this morning the criminal
case against him continues while the
clark county district attorney says the
civil division of his office is also
working against him 8 news now
investigator vanessa murphy explains
robert tellis will continue to be held
with no bail that's why the clark county
district attorney's office is making an
effort to remove him from his position
as clark county public administrator
while he's in jail accused of murder
telus is still getting paid for the job
tellis is accused of killing review
journal investigative journalist jeff
german after gearman exposed problems
under the leadership of telus including
a possible inappropriate relationship
here he is making a quick appearance in
court tuesday he'll now be represented
by the clark county public defender's
office do you understand the charge the
next court date is scheduled about a
month away coming up later on 8 news now
we'll have more from clark county
district attorney steve wolfson about
this high profile criminal case
reporting in downtown las vegas at the
regional justice center vanessa murphy 8
news now